ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show there's gonna be some
background noise here you shut the
up about it
we're doing a video episode for you pigs
you want it you get it
we're out here in montauk in an airbnb i
was promised
that this was going to be a luxury
experience and it is not
and i am unhappy about it i got a
table of six squawking birds over there
which i don't like and i got
a guy on his mower okay and i hope to
god he's doing it because he enjoys it
because if i look over there and i see
that he's an employee
and i have to look at those people i'm
going to lose my mind
so i hope to christ he's driving a john
deere
because he enjoys it okay and it is not
a worker
while i'm sitting here in this
that was b it was
supposed to be a surf cottage what a
working class hell montauk is
i was in the hamptons i came back to see
my
family who will die of cover 19
in the second wave i will make sure of
it culver 19 may leave bullet holes in
them
and strangulation marks around their
neck they're going down by november
they're going down by november i don't
care i don't care okay
and i went to see them i got an airbnb
on that part of long island
the south shore i was sitting outside
with two friends
dan is producing the show today because
ben is back in california
uh and dan is here because he doesn't
have a life so
he's producing the show i was here with
dan and luke
uh luke opens for me and uh
i mean i swear to christ with the
lawnmower i'm gonna break
someone's head
here i really am for the love of god
they don't even have a couch in the
living room here it's
two wood benches that they've put
blankets on
like we're in a methadone clinic here
and everything the whole house is
littered with native american
memorabilia
and by the way i'm a supporter of the
native americans many of you know that
but this house is owned by some white
who's decorated it all with
you know kokopelli and dream catchers
and everything
it's it's just not tasteful how bad is
this background noise getting
pretty bad it's hard to tell hard to
tell
it's hard to tell we have a
mower and we got six we got six
squawking birds
having a real white zen night out here
in montauk
getting their opinions out squawking
birds
and a mower we're doing the best we can
we got a real
dinner party over there the cops will be
here shortly trust me they're coming
they came last night me and and luke and
dan were discussing
race relations in america i swear to god
i swear to god i said this sentence how
do we get race relations to a better
position
and after that sense the neighbor on
long island came came over and said hey
can you cut it out over there
can you cut it out over there and then
he called the police
what do you think that call was he calls
up the cop and he goes by the way the
guy next to me is trying to he's talking
about bettering the lives of black
americans
please come get him please come shut him
down
so this cop shows up at the airbnb and
he's like oh i was called to the side of
a party
and there's no party here i said yeah
there's no party we're just having a
conversation i didn't tell the cop about
what
i didn't say we're having a conversation
about some of the activities you people
have been participating in
we're having a conversation about you
people be a little trick or
happy i don't want to have that
conversation i want to have a nice
conversation about italian ice
it's the end of summer but because you
people can't put the gun in the
toddler's face
you can't stop doing that i have to sit
in my backyard and talk about these
things
does it make me happy we did lose a
patreon subscriber recently and i don't
usually
uh go into this but this is weird this
was a young dude who listened to the
show
i don't know him i i don't i don't i
don't think i've ever met him
a guy named kyle rittenhouse uh deleted
his patreon subscription so
um hey man there's a lot of good
entertainment that you're missing out on
uh i don't know what your deal is but
the reality is
there's a lot of good stuff
coming on the patreon it was a little
strange
that he i mean are we gonna keep it up
with the why are they doing this i hate
my talk
it's a working class hell i want wasps
god damn it i want porcelain-skinned
wasps eating silently eating
flounder and i'm here in this hellscape
of surfers and fishermen it's
like a billy joel wet dream this
town bomb it damn it to hell i think the
girls have
i think the girls have quieted down now
they know that
they know that someone with an intellect
is here but i'll tell you this folks
the police will be coming probably
shortly probably in the middle of the
show uh hopefully not during an ad read
but what are you going to do who's that
somebody come over yeah people are
wandering
people are wandering over good for them
can wander back to their trailers
this is not luxury no there's an animal
skull on the table behind us i mean we
were promised
i was promised a luxurious experience
i i i mean what is happening
i mean it's it's a complete it's really
truly a complete hell
and uh and i obviously i don't want to
sound ungrateful because i know there's
18 million americans out of work or 17.8
million americans
out of work uh and all of them and
that's just comedians
all of them are just stand-up comedians
sadly but i i
you know i'm just saying that when you
promise an experience you deliver the
experience you don't deliver
this surf cottage we've gotta
we've got a with a skull of a bison in
there
some horns coming out like it's like
it's a scene at a true detective
i don't like it of course we're kidding
about kyle rittenhouse he was not on the
patreon
by the way how do we feel about that
everybody that's a new thing everyone's
discussing right now
i stayed away from that one on twitter
it seemed very hot
seemed very hot that discussion about uh
kyle rittenhouse and his gun
uh he went out there was a protest in
there
kenosha is that the way to pronounce it
kenosha wisconsin about the shooting of
jacob blake
kyle rittenhouse went to the protest
with his mother
mama written house mama bear written
house
also i believe armed
they're an armed family
so mama bear rittenhouse took baby bear
to the protest and baby bear brought it
was it what is it an ar-15 or an ak what
did he bring i don't know what he
brought
but i know that people are getting mad
that people are confusing those things
so like
hey before you comment on this how about
figuring out the difference between an
ar
and an ak it's like yeah but also how
about just not having teenagers running
through the town square with them no
matter which one it is
how about we not substitute junior prom
with a shoot em up
that's just my thoughts but whatever
automatic weapon he had
it's actually not automatic tim it's
it's you know
whatever so he shows up with a gun i
don't know what he's doing i don't know
if he's i've commented on this before
i've spoken now it seems like ad nauseam
about what happens when you defund and
abolish
uh police you will have militias you
will have
i've never in my life by the way heard
this dirty working-class
pig on his mower for so long i hope to
god he blows his brains out
on his goddamn mower i hate people that
mow their own lawn
but i do hope that if i do get a glimpse
of him it is
someone who's mowing their own lawn and
not a worker because i'm pro-worker
so in this situation i'd like my rage to
be directed at the owner of the property
but i don't know who it is if it's
someone just doing their job i'm not as
mad at it
but if it's just some hedge fund
piece of
who's doing his own lawn because
he i want to feel like a real man
i just bankrupted ecuador and i want to
feel like a man
so i surf and mow my own lawn
there's a cute little bunny here you
can't see it but i'm gonna break its
neck shortly and dip it in uh frank's
red hot
that's right that's where you're going
but my point about the
uh the written house situation
is this is what's gonna happen it's
predictable
when you have chaos riots looting you
will have
people some of them children are picking
up weapons
uh for no reason are they well is he
defending the
who's he defense some people will defend
their businesses
some people just like chaos some people
like violence some people are quite
bored
they're bored and they say what's going
on
downtown tonight is it a parade
no it's kind of a parade but everybody's
bringing a weapon let's see what we're
gonna get into
and some people go well that sounds like
a fun idea
let's grab the guns getting the get in
the buggy and head down to town
so we're analyzing it the wrong way
we're trying to look at it we're trying
to be like
but should he have well i don't
understand
maybe no people are bored and they have
weapons
it's not a good mix you see it's a
combustible
mix when bored people have access to
machinery of death
because they tend to use that they want
to go out
they're bored they don't have any jobs
they've closed down the movie theater
so you can't go see fast and furious 27
okay you can't meet a nice woman and try
to get a hand job by the popcorn machine
you have to try to overthrow the
government now if you want any fun
if you want to get your jollies you're
leaving your house so mama bear written
house and baby bear
grabbed the aks or the ars or whatever
they had the elephant gun the uzi
i don't know not an expert okay they get
in the buggy and they head down
to a kenosha wisconsin uh the city
center where the
black lives matter movement had been uh
lighting up the uh the cars and the uh
the dealerships and uh they lit up a few
uh
dealerships and i saw what else did they
get over there do you see what they got
they got a few
few other things were you paying
attention i don't care about this
the reality is well that's good that's
why you're on unemployment when that
runs out it's over
uh so the the black lives matter people
they come in and they uh they're they're
they're
looting and there's uh some chaos and
there's some uh
skirmishes some fighting okay and then
you have look something up on this by
the way cause i don't wanna be wrong
about this it seems rather important
and then you have a written house you
see the video i watched the video on the
kid he's being chased he has a gun he's
being chased somebody kicks him in the
head and then he gets up he sits up and
he starts shooting
firing and then after that i think he
runs towards police and people are angry
that the police gave him a bottle of
water
and they patted him on the head and they
didn't shoot him well let's be a little
consistent folks
do we want the police shooting people or
not how do we want this to play out do
we want the police to just knee-jerk
reaction
start shooting people as a general rule
i don't think we do
right that's not what we want in fact
i believe we're campaigning to reverse
that behavior
but kyle went to the now i did find it a
little suspect
that the cops you know let let him drive
himself to the police station
that i didn't like i didn't think that
it was right that they had a ticker tate
parade for him
i thought that was very strange uh when
they were chanting his name kyle
kyle that i didn't like i thought that
was very odd
so there were there was behavior that
they engaged in
that was disappointing to me uh from the
thing of law enforcement many of them
just started making out with him when he
walked over they just started
deep mouth kissing him i found that odd
he's a minor but they were they were
seemingly very supportive of him
uh there was a lot of high fiving going
on when he stepped over there
so again there are things that shouldn't
escape uh
you know the world's uh uh you know
i we should be looking at these things
but
kyle was then uh taken in by the police
now he's booked on i believe
uh first degree murder charges in
wisconsin this is what i believe
is happening and then this is the big
to-do everybody is deciding
was it right or was it wrong what he did
and what happened well here's my
position my position is this
um as a general rule when there is going
to be
a civil unrest i tend to go the other
way
i recommend an airbnb something by the
mountains the desert i enjoy the beach
i prefer that now some people like to go
into the eye of the storm
so to speak with a weapon now that is
that is your prerogative but
when you do that you understand that
things are going to happen many of those
things
unpredictable and unfortunate maybe he
was defending the local business
i don't know i don't like any business
enough to defend
i don't like any of my family enough to
defend in fact if black lives matter was
killing my family right now i would not
show up
to defend my family i would actually
tweet and support
of whatever activity they were doing i
mean i'm talking about blm
stomping my parents out in the middle of
the street i'm telling you i would
not go in the direction of that i might
feel bad for my parents
i would be like oh well that's not good
but i wouldn't get
in a car and head to their house with a
a weapon well that and maybe that
speaks to my character maybe i should do
that but
i just feel like this guy probably
doesn't have a lot of guidance in his
life
mama bear rittenhouse probably not
mother of the year she's driving her son
to a protest he's heavily armed this
doesn't seem like the best
idea i don't know what this was maybe
they thought it was going to be just a
show of force they were going to march
around with the weapons i don't know but
again
when this type of thing happens the
looting the burning the chaos
i suggest palm springs
the hamptons these are the nice places
jacksonville
not much i'm haunted god help you it was
the smith wesson
i would rather be getting my skull cuck
kicked in right now by antifa
than being this hole my
point is this
coeur d'alene idaho is nice these are
nice places
and i'm only of course i'm naming the
rich places because i'm being funny
but there's a lot of other areas that
aren't expensive that you can go
you can leave you can leave kenosha
wisconsin and go somewhere else
till things quiet down
try to get away until things simmer down
that's my general rule
now you can go and march with a weapon i
i just find it to be probably not too
smart
and now this kid's got a first degree
murder charge and that's that's what
i've got to say about that i don't i
don't know the kid i don't know the
family i you know all these people are
i mean i feel like they might be a bit
off
but i don't know i don't know it's not
like i have any
love loss i mean these protesters are
anarchists they want to burn down the
city
they're not getting anything out of this
this is about violence and chaos
it is not a political movement it does
not have a political goal
it does not have uh points uh it does
not have a leader
it does there's no attempted
negotiations there's very few demands
that are realistic
other than like eat the rich or end
capitalism
which seems as a demand to be a bit
lofty of an ideal
per se so again we're seeing this as a
as a movement which agitators and
anarchists are people going to take
advantage of
the united states government might send
people into that movement to further
delegitimize it
they've done it with every protest
movement ever every counter culture
movement in america has been subverted
by the fbi look up cointelpro look up
any of these things
okay um so at the end of the day you you
do not know who's in that crowd when
everybody's got a black mask on and
everybody's just throwing molotov
cocktails
you don't know who's in that crowd why
they're in their crowd what they're
doing okay
it you know when you see the uh
uh all that those antifa people or
whoever they are i don't even know who
they are
i would imagine this is we're just
calling everybody wearing black antifa
now
which and that there probably are large
numbers of them
but they're yelling at this woman who's
eating in washington dc and there's all
of them and they're screaming and
they're getting in her face
and they're going black lives matter i
mean i'll tell you right now that is a
trump campaign
ad it is a trump campaign ad
to be honest when you see things like
that and you go is the other side just
pure chaos
is the other side pure chaos and are
they excusing chaos are they telling
police to stand down
and are they not prosecuting people who
are destroying your property your
business
your way of earning money that becomes a
big problem so that becomes a campaign
ad
right there i don't know who's in that
crowd i don't know who those protesters
are
i don't know who they are i don't know
if they're stupid kids i don't know if
they're anarchists
i don't know if they're undercover feds
i don't know if they're foreign
agitators i don't know if from other
countries i don't know
what they're doing okay because
everybody's standing there
dressed in black their faces are covered
we have no idea it's like twitter
this is twitter come to life you look at
twitter you have no idea who these
people are these bots
you see the same tweet over and over and
over again you go
this is not a real person this
is a form of bots or something
what is it it's not real you look at
these avatars and
you know it's just it's just it's not
real people
so when you look out there and you see
this is the physical manifestation of
twitter
but are they real people who are they i
mean they're they're living breathing
things with flash sure but what are they
doing
what do they want how many different
groups of people are involved in
something like that
when something goes down in in kenosha
wisconsin
how many of those people are just trying
to grab
some stuff because they've been
unemployed for three months
how many of those people legitimately
agree with the movement how many of
those people
are bored and just want to go
out and light up
because you know what after four months
of not working and the government gives
you 1200
watching burn is funny i'm thinking
of lighting this airbnb
up i'm thinking lighting this airbnb up
and watching all these pictures
native americans burn
that this white put in there okay
i'm gonna i'll be
by the end of this podcast i'm gonna be
hardcore blm
she's appropriated the native american
culture and she's put it around this
shitty surf
cottage but
this is why you have to look you step
back when you see these protests you see
this happening you're like things
are unfolding
at a mile a minute it's very fast paced
you look at these things
some of these people seem like highly
trained teams of
anarchists where you go there's four or
six of them they're working in a cell
they know what they're doing they're
looking at each other they're working
they're coordinating with each other one
person is
you know you know tossing gasoline the
other person's throwing the match
one person's lookout they seem like this
is a coordinated thing
and you go who are they is that antifa
is that
uh are they people that are looking to
burn down this this building as a
diversionary tactic to go do something
else to go loot to go steal to go rob
are these undercover fbi cia people that
just want to
take peaceful protest and turn them into
something that
everybody's against which is very easy
a peaceful protest of a hundred thousand
people is very powerful
you start breaking windows and burning
things down all of a sudden that very
powerful
political statement now becomes
something that most people are against
and they go what is this
so i don't know who's doing what
but i do know that it is probably not a
good idea to walk into one of these
protests
with a ak-47 or an ar-15 or whatever it
is
it's probably not a good idea okay this
is not a good idea
you know you know no matter what happens
the media is not going to have your back
okay and i'm not saying the media should
have your back i'm not commenting on
this particular
situation i'm just saying when things go
haywire when society collapses
you don't go try to figure it out you
don't go to the middle of the town
square and go what's going on here
you leave you go
people can become animals very quickly
you ever try to reason with a bear
what are you doing this is not what you
do
you get away until things simmer the
down
they cool the down and the people
can deal with logic and reason
nobody burning things down in
in the heat of that moment is dealing
with logic and reason
so going in there and i just it was it
was a hot topic on twitter like people
were going after each other
and i i just didn't know i don't
i i really don't know all i know is this
as a general rule it's probably a good
idea to stay the away
when things go haywire and not try to
make sense of it
and not show up to defend the local gas
station or the local target or the big
guy
or even even listen even if it's a
you know most of these businesses are
insured even if it's a small business
i'm not i i do not believe it's right
that those small businesses are are
burning down
but a lot of those people have insurance
um
i don't think anything's worth losing
your life over
or losing your freedom over obviously if
they're attacking your home
or your family it's a different
situation but to just walk into the
center of town and go
let's figure this out this is the
job of the police
this is why you have a police force this
is the job of the police
and if these if these people are not
going to let them do their job
and uh this is also the job of actual
legitimate activists to
constrain these movements and make them
productive
and not let them become these big tents
for people that just want to destroy
things and rob people
you're going to have to actually exert
some power over the movement
and a lot of these people doing this
are white let's be honest and this
is a black lives matter movement
so that's kind of what i have to say
about that um
you got to give up cigarettes folks i
did it we're all doing it you got to do
it lucy nicotine is a company founded by
caltech scientists they've spent three
years
on great products nicotine gum that
comes in three flavors wintergreen
uh pomegranate and silica cinnamon they
also have lozenges
they're great you can enjoy them
anywhere at work on a flight it doesn't
matter
have four milligrams of nicotine you get
your buzz you're good when you quit
cigarettes it puts a lot of strain on
your friends your family
your job you want to be able to perform
and and and be a good person
while you get the nicotine out of your
system the tar and all the carcinogens
so
you find a nicotine replacement like
lucy okay
it's very very easy get rid of the vape
vaping is not good this is not what you
want to do
you don't want to be dipping you don't
want any of that you don't want mouth
cancer you don't want a hole in your
throat
okay i'm telling you right now you got
to go to lucy.co
and use promo code tim lucy.co
use promo code tim to get 20 off all
products including gum or
lozenges that's lucy.co okay
also i have to give this disclaimer
warning this product contains nicotine
derived from tobacco nicotine is an
addictive chemical
okay lucy.co and the promo code is tim
it's the end of summer it's time to get
serious let's do it you're worth it it's
important
i i've smoked a lot of cigarettes in my
life and i'll regret it one day
but right now i'm not smoking this thing
has really helped me
it's the best decision i've ever made i
think you should make it too i don't
want to be one of those people with a
vape
i'm not dipping take i'm telling you the
lozenges are great
the gum is great you get your buzz you
move on about your day
you wean yourself off it and then all of
a sudden you don't need anything anymore
so that's lucy.co
promo code tim at checkout i'm using
these i
i i support these i support you
folks the thing with beds whenever you
check into a hotel or an airbnb you go i
hope the mattress is great right you
stay at a friend's house you're like man
i hope the mattress is good
why because it's all guesswork you don't
know
helix is different helix gives you a
quiz you design your own mattress the
amount of firmness
softness are you a front sleeper a side
sleeper helix.com
really enables you to custom custom
design your mattress to curate your own
sleep experience
that's so important the anxiety of a bad
night of sleep i mean if you're not
sleeping you're not thinking clearly you
don't know what's going on
i mean you're not productive at work or
at home your relationships suffer you
gotta sleep
okay everybody is unique helix knows
that they have several different
mattress models to choose from
they have soft medium firm mattresses
mattress is great for cooling you down
if you sleep hot
and then even have a helix plus mattress
for you plus size folks who were those
people
i took the helix quiz and i was matched
with the model mattress that
i wanted i mean it's amazing listen so
you just have to go to a quiz
it's easy okay helixsleep.com
tim dillon take the two minute sleep
quiz you have nothing to lose it's not
like you have to buy something
just go to helixsleep.com tim dillon
take their two minute sleep quiz and
they'll match you to a customized
mattress that will give you the best
sleep of your life
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for a hundred nights risk
free
that's how confident they are in the
product okay i'm telling you
it removes all of the anxiety out of out
of
out of buying a mattress that you don't
like in a month you help
you design your your your own mattress
you get a hundred nights for free
it is the best thing that you could do
i'm telling you helix is offering up to
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners
at helix sleep.com tim dillon i'm gonna
say that again
because man is that a wow helix
is offering up to 200
off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners
at helixsleep.com tim
dillon you get that i'm telling you
right now folks
it is very very important that you get a
good night's sleep so go to
helixleep.com
tim dillon it's easy it's essential
you should do it this will change your
life i'm telling you right now if o.j
simpson got a good night's sleep
he would not have killed his wife if he
did which i don't think he did
but i'm just using that example do you
understand what i mean
i think oj is innocent free oj he's free
i follow him on twitter but i'm saying
if he killed his wife it's because he
did not get a good night's sleep
yes or yes so go to helixsleep.com tim
dillon in other news i was in new york
city we filmed a very funny video in new
york city and
new york city i mean we're going into
new york city like we're expecting
kenosha wisconsin
we think it's we're going to get knifed
beaten stabbed
shot we think we're going to be killed
we're planning how to do this video and
then get right back in the rental car
we're imagining lurid you know
scenes i am legend every zombie disaster
movie
you've ever seen we're thinking about
just you know young
kids running around robbing you pelting
you with rocks
okay or imagine boarded up storefronts
people crawling on the street
we're thinking about just pools of blood
that are gathering at the corners of the
streets
we're thinking that it's going to be a
horror it's going to be a
post-apocalyptic
hellscape and we get there and it's
lovely it's paradise it's
actually nicer than it was yes there's
some shootings you're gonna get shot
you're gonna get shot maybe
but maybe not the rents are falling it's
it's really nice people are out they're
walking their dogs covered rates are low
the restaurants are open for dinner
people are a few of them recognize me i
love the show this is nice thank you i'm
walking around i got
gashes of blood all over me it's great
by the way you know what's funny
what's really great is that you know
that no one cares about you
when you facetime them they don't know
you're doing the video you facetime them
and you have deep gashes in your face
and you're bleeding and they don't know
it's makeup and they still don't care
that's how you know you've really
surrounded yourself with a great class
of people
it's really really good my dad was like
what's going on
why are you bleeding that's the boomer
response to everything
it's just light laughter and confusion
[Laughter]
christina is but his face is bleeding
he has a gash in his face why is your
face bleeding
are you dying he is dying
my son is dying
i mean i was shocked at how nice
how beautiful new york was and how you
know i i remember it you know i love you
i would never live there again
but i just i i loved it man i love
walking by and a guy like you you're a
young guy you should be there if you're
a young person
move to new york date meet young people
get stabbed if you have to take a bullet
gives you a little character gives you a
little story
but i'm telling you right now i i think
the media has hyped this up
and this whole james altucher who i like
he's a sweet guy he's like a bootleg
malcolm gladwell and i and i and i mean
and i don't mean that to offend him but
he looks like malcolm gladwell
he's a big fan of this podcast i'll
teacher he's uh he's
a really nice guy he's a fan of comedy
he's a comedian to some degree
um and i and he owns he's a part owner
of standup new york
which is one of the worst comedy clubs
in the country
uh and a place where every time i have
to perform i've considered blowing my
brains out
on the way there instead i do it and and
it's fine
listen i'm not i'm a kid i kid them and
i don't i don't care
about working there anymore but i'm
backing governors love governors thank
you we
we healed our wounds and we're and we're
now back together we're back together
and we'll do that with standard new york
too if they get because i can sell
little tickets now so
they'll be okay it's it's a massage
front it is what it is thank you
anyway i did a new year's eve show there
once and the owner brought in like three
tables of people and they were eating
food
out of like big tins and it's it's a
massage front for weapons for the uh
for the uh uh idf anyway moving on
doesn't matter who cares
anyway it doesn't matter al tucha is a
part owner of this business why because
it's a scam
and he's like a bitcoin guy and he's
involved in all kinds of different
things which i appreciate
his new thing's going to be like
doomsday prepper he's going to be
selling
uh you know doomsday prep kits hey you
can run your business from your doomsday
hole you know
10 tips for the modern business prep but
dan's nervous because he wants to work
these clubs
but i don't care but james is a
sweetheart of a guy right he bought into
this massage scam
and he he does like you know every now
and then he'll do a bitcoin seminar in
between two of the comics which is very
helpful for a show
you know i'll get up do jokes and then
he'll come up and talk about ethereum
so
we're having fun i'm sure he enjoys this
my my job is my job folks
so james bought into uh a stand-up new
york massage scam
and he they just made the bartender the
booker once
they just they just wanted the mexican
guys that was wiping off the table they
go now you booked the club he goes
oh okay who what what
okay here is lineup godfrey
godfrey
tim dillon uh i don't i don't know who's
who is this
uh lori kilmartin ah okay
you're the booker now you washed the
dishes now you booked the club now you
curate the entertainment for the
audience
they just give everything the homeless
guy across the street was the booker you
used to have to go and audition for him
he was blind so he would have to you
know
feel your face with his fingers anyway
so al tutor buys into this club
which is and by the way the new york
times jason zinniman the
the writer for the new york times comedy
section he still has a job
amazing maybe the recession isn't that
bad
jason who i like who's been on the
program open invitation again unlike mag
right at vulture who will not come on i
don't know why i'm respectful to
everyone
come on but she doesn't want to leave
her apartment she's cocooned in there
with many cats don't know
but come on let's talk i i don't even
hate her i don't
like what she does but i don't hate her
i like that archetype of woman who's
like
kind of strange and you know but
committed to her work like i like i like
a
like a monastery type of like just
typing and i
like i'm like that i don't have friends
and things i like what she's doing
come and join me and we'll sit at
opposite ends of the table and we'll
talk about how our careers or our lives
and our lives are horrible
yes or yes meg so jason wrote this whole
thing about how
it's so great to do stand-up comedy in
central park and
you know on on the shores of the east
river and in a cab
it's so nice and the state of new york
is producing a lot of these outdoor
comedy shows now because people when
people just get out of a four-month
coven isolation and they're laying in
the park what they really want is
somebody yelling about their
that's what they want they're just
trying to set to be in the park with
their family and they need
some insecure psychopath babbling in the
park
so james l tucher part owner of stand-up
new york who's on the avant-garde here
and on the vanguard of all these new uh
comedy experiences curating all these
comedy experiences
in the park uh james o'tooter writes an
article called new york is dead
and it's never coming back and people
are very very angry about that because
i'll teach her
very smart guy knows what he's doing a
little bit of a troll
knows what he's going to do when he says
new york's dead what's gonna happen
who's gonna puff up their chest some
gazillionaire
like jerry seinfeld
so jerry seinfeld who is
a legend a king whatever you want he's
great it is what it is
probably wouldn't love me but wouldn't
like my comedy maybe he would don't know
so jerry writes an article saying hey
new york's gonna be okay
it is what it is you know and that's the
whole article i mean there's more
parts of it but you know it's not that
funny but it's
fun and it's jerry going uh hey he goes
yeah i've never been to new york i have
a house in long island which is i mean
he's in a state in hampton's house
but whatever he's allowed to say that
right it is what it is so everybody
you know so jerry goes new york's gonna
be fine everybody's gonna be fine shut
the up
and i saw him recently out here in the
hamptons
jerry and he was just pulling he was
pulling the the masks off
off off waiters and waitresses and then
deep mouth kissing them
and gender unimportant and then kiss him
and then he would say new york is back
and he'd say open your mouth and
then he'd spit in their mouth and i was
like that's the type of guy
that i think is important to have i
think he needs someone who's kind of
tough like that and who's really
has a passion for the city i like that i
saw him hit a hit of maid with his car
and he just said new york's back
and kept driving and that i like that
but so jerry got in the new york times
and just basically did
a takedown of altu and he called them a
putts
i love jerry seinfeld insults they're
like from 1935.
this guy's the putts he's a louse
this this look at this carnival barker
so jerry's insulting this guy with
depression-era slang
in the new york times i think altucha
responds in the post
and it's just been a knockdown drag out
of rich guys
who don't live in the city currently
arguing about if the city is going to be
back
and guys the city is already back it's
actually
doing fine i mean things aren't open
things will open but the city is doing
fine yes there is crime there are
problems
there are issues with the police from
what i gather
but the city itself is actually okay
so we have this tug of war between james
altucher it's stand-up new york and of
course i kid stand up new york
i love you guys i'd love to perform on a
barge in the east river
if you have my email and you have james
altucher going at
a legendary king of the hamptons jerry
seinfeld
and they just it's a knock down throw
down fight the two men are much more
successful than your humble
podcaster here so all i say is hey it's
fun
i want to write a third article called
new york's not dead but let's
kill it and it would be outlining the
reasons to kill new york and how to do
it
that would be the humorous take which
jerry and altucher decided not to be
humorous in their articles
following the ethos of comedy right now
to be very serious
all the time and make tiny little jokes
kind of
that's what we do and that's who we give
specials to and those people become
uh millionaires but i would like to
write an article called new york is not
dead but
me if i ain't gonna try let's kill
it
here's how to kill it and i would then
just list you know
an eight-point plan or a ten point plan
about how to destroy uh new york city i
think that would be
that would be fun i don't know if that's
gonna happen or not
probably not but you know we will see
but that that's been a very interesting
war that has been brewing uh in the
comedy world that is uh what the comedy
world has been kind of talking about and
what
it's bled out into uh anybody that's on
twitter or really anybody that's
in new york's probably come across one
of those articles
saying that new york is dead forever and
here's why and i'll teach you made some
good points he said the internet speed
allows you to conduct business wherever
you want
so why the hell are you doing in new
york and jerry seinfeld's whole point
was that uh which i thought was also a
good point he's like
where else can you kill a maid and then
have it covered up in under six hours
and have her body buried in the park so
both of them
have a good point and i think both of
them should
be heard and by the way guys
you are so welcome to come on the show
you're so welcome to come on the show
jerry and al tucher
and me just a couple of guys just a
couple of guys that want the best for
the greatest
city in the world okay and i'll rent a
nice airbnb i won't be here in this uh
montauk surf
i'm gonna burn this place down you got
to be on ayahuasca to think this is a
nice place i paid for luxury experience
and i didn't get it
and when i'm promised luxury and i don't
get it i squeal like a pig
i squeal like a pig like a privileged
vindictive petty little pig that's a
petty little pig
if you heard me squealing from a mile
away you'd go that
pig didn't get luxury that pig was
expecting luxury and didn't get it
what a petty little pig and i'd go
i'd make a sound like that and i
wouldn't stop
and they'd toss and turn in their beds
and they wouldn't be able to sleep
and the kids would run into the rooms
and the kids would go why can't i sleep
there's this blood
curdling scream and the parents would
say
son i'll tell you i'll tell you a lesson
you're going to learn a lesson right now
if you promise
a pig luxury you better deliver
because if you don't that pig will
scream until that pig can scream no more
do you understand that daddy why is
luxury so important to the pig
well the pig has a little else son the
pig likes the luxury the pig likes the
creature comforts
that is why pigs exist to put themselves
in situations where they can get
creature comforts
and if they are promised these things
and they don't get them they believe
that the entire world should be burned
to the ground son
even our family yes yes
a pig who's promised luxury and not
delivered it would watch you your sister
me and your mother
burn to death without a tear in his eye
no emotion
because a pig deserves luxury i don't
deserve
wooden benches with a
blanket over them
how dare you how dare you and i don't
usually leave
bad reviews on the airbnb but i'm going
to write
on airbnb that this woman uh had
clan memorabilia in her house i'm going
to say that i was very uncomfortable
by a room in her house that was
dedicated to a history of the klu klux
klan
which her grandfather was in and she was
very proud of she said i'm very proud of
my heritage by the way she texted me
that she's like the last people at a
party of six people it was a big deal
there was trash all over the yard people
have food out
please don't be that guy and i'm like
i'm not gonna be that guy i do the same
thing in every airbnb this is my two
week end of summer vacation then we'll
be back in the studio
next week every airbnb i sit in the
backyard and i scream for several hours
into a microphone that is my job the guy
yesterday is like i calls the cops i'm
like
it's my job sir my job isn't like your
job to just go around and shoot people
whenever you feel like it
my job is to communicate with the body
politic
with the public i have to speak to the
public it's not my fault
we're all looking for ways to save money
especially now when's the last time you
looked at how much you're spending every
month on car insurance i'm telling you
you spend a lot i spend a lot
i've totaled five cars and i've had
multiple suspended licenses
but you know what i'm telling you gabby
takes the pain out of shopping for
insurance by giving you
an apples to apples comparison of your
current coverage with 40 of the top
insurance providers
progressive nationwide and travelers
just link your current insurance account
and in about two minutes
you'll be able to see quotes for the
exact same coverage you currently have
okay i love gabby to help me get cheap
car insurance and i was challenging
gabby customers saved 825 per year on
average i think i'm saving about 700.
if they could find you savings like they
did for me they'll let you know
that you can relax knowing you have the
best rate out there and they'll never
sell your info which i really like so no
annoying spam or robo calls okay
so if you if you have car insurance
you're paying a lot for it maybe you
haven't up in a while you haven't
had a ticket you haven't been pulled
over
you've been doing the right thing and
you know you've got a high rate with a
progressive or someone else
you can basically plug in
uh your insurance information into gabby
they work with all kinds of different
insurers they will match
the type of insurance you have right now
and see if there is a better option for
you if there's not there's not who cares
but if there is why would you not save
money it's totally free to check your
rate
there's no obligation takes two minutes
right now to see how much you can save
on your car
and homeowners insurance too that's
important
go to gabby.com tim dillon that's
g-a-b-i
dot-com tim dillon g-a-b-i dot com slash
tim dillon truly i love these things
because you know what
if you're like me and you don't know
about this stuff you just say you know
what
put your information in see what comes
up and listen if you don't want to
change it you don't have to change it
but just know what your options are i'm
a big fan of knowing what your options
are
it's super important you know big fan of
that so that's
g-a-b-i dot com slash tim dillon
gabby.com tim dillon this is an
essential part
of uh trying to get yourself financially
in a better shape we're heading into a
vicious year
we don't know where the economy is going
you need every dollar and if you can
find out how much
you're overpaying on car insurance
that's the best thing to do
so that's g-a-b-i dot-com tim
dillon do it tell me how much you saved
tell me how much you saved i mean i'm
interested to hear
you know i mean i wouldn't i wouldn't uh
tell you to do this if i thought you
couldn't save anything
and many of you won't save anything
maybe probably won't because you're
animals you know
i don't know what you're doing in there
you're probably driving illegal yeah you
know
maybe you killed somebody with your car
you probably killed a family of four
on the long island expressway because
you're driving the wrong way what do i
know what you did
but even if you are one of those people
and you were charged you served ten
years
for vehicular homicide still
go to gabi.com tim dillon
that's gabby.com tim dillon and explain
to them that you had a vehicular
homicide
where you killed an entire family but
you're looking to save money
thank you ridge wallet yum
i mean ridge wallet how many
times have we told you to get ridge
wallet it is a small
front facing minimalist sleek metal
wallet that is so easy to sanitize it is
not leather
it is not annoying it is small it goes
in your front pocket nobody knows you
have it on you it doesn't bulge in your
pocket
nobody's going to come mug you it is the
perfect wallet for the situation
that we find ourselves in it it comes
with titanium carbon fiber a bunch of
cool
flavors layout if you i mean i'm telling
you this is
this is the wallet for you it's a while
for you it's a wallet for everybody okay
i'm telling you it's very very very
important
you know go there see what wallet you
like it's very important
ridge.com tim you know what it is you
get 10
off your order ridge.com tim you get 10
off your order if you're annoyed with
your current wallet if you want to
support me if you like the show and you
need a new wallet
try out a ridge it forces you to
streamline everything in your life
your cash your credit cards you know you
put a debit card a credit card in there
maybe a hundred dollar bill your
attorney's uh card you're done
you're done next to kin or somebody to
call in case of emergency and that's
it what do you really need in a
wallet so many times i've talked about
my dad's wallet how embarrassing it was
he'd open it up all these business cards
would fall out
of people he couldn't get to do business
with them crumpled up ones i mean it was
a nightmare
but you're not gonna have that
experience you put a ridge on the bar a
woman wants to you
a man wants to you everybody wants
to you
when you put a ridge wallet on the bar
because people go what's that oh it's
this new thing don't worry about it you
know
play it cool play it cool i'm telling
you it's very important everybody
that's a fan of this show a lot of us
have ridge wallets you know i mean it's
very very important you got to go to
ridge.com
tim it is very very important do you
have ridge wallet
of course it's beautiful what do you
think about it i love it good
ridge.com t-i-m it's so
important right now to have a sleek
slender
sexy wallet for the end of the world so
that's ridge.com
tim do not do what my father did which
was order for them without the promo
code that is a waste of all of our times
thank you but i do i will miss this area
i do love this area man
there's great people watching we had
lunch today and we walked into this
place called the american hotel in sag
harbor and they're just
old ancient people here man there was a
woman when we walked in who looked like
a grouper
just a fat lady looked like a grouper
and her two
friends or daughters were each had gray
hair and they were like terrified you
could tell they were terrified of this
woman
she was the grouper she was the boss and
she sat in the corner of the restaurant
in the corner seat
and you could tell she controls the
purse strings you know she
she carves it all up and her will is
malleable
you know she can just take out an eraser
and ruin your life or
with a flick of repent she can change
your life and they know that
because eventually the grouper is going
to do herself in it's just going to be a
little too much chocolate mousse and
then
so it's just great to watch
the birds it's just great to uh to
observe people like that in their
natural habitat it's very interesting
it's
it's a life that i'll know nothing about
except from the outside
i suspect it's very boring i suspect the
fantasy life i want to live like
finance and these elite groups of people
i suspect it's very boring that's what
i've heard from certain people
that have lived that life um but i don't
know
that's my suspicion uh like my life's
kind of boring you know you think i have
all these interesting friends
and they're all funny and everything and
it's like not
kind of true but some of them aren't for
sure and a lot of them aren't
but it's not as fun as you'd think it's
actually not as fun as you'd think and
most people are sitting there now going
no we think your life's horrible we know
that that's why we tune in every week
because i will blow my head off on the
show one day uh in the middle of an ad
read from magic spoon cereal i'll just
blow my brains out
i want to destroy a brand when i go like
i
want i want you know bud dwyer remember
that i want my suicide to be
always attached to magic spoon keto
cereal
so that like is anytime it comes up
somebody goes is that the one where the
guy blew his and they go yeah
yeah that's it they'll have to change
their name and everything i think it'll
be a lot of fun
um but uh yeah so i'll be back we're
gonna be back
in california and that's coming we're
coming back to the desert on thursday
we're going to start doing shows in the
studio again
we've got a great show coming up we hope
it's a great show at the stress factory
in new brunswick new jersey
uh governor meatball cuomo and his
brother chris fredo
uh corleone uh cancelled
uh my shows and we know that they're
goons and they're
run a crime family so they canceled my
shows and they didn't allow me to speak
in my home state
they would not allow me to speak in my
home state
wow but that's okay i went to the next
state over where it's still a
representative democracy it's america
apparently and i will be performing uh
in a parking lot
and i'm very excited about that and then
i will head back to the desert and then
i hibernate i hibernate probably through
the
the fall in the winter depending on what
the second wave is doing and if we can
get back out there
but as soon as we can get back out there
on the road we're gonna get back out
there on the road because i'm just
getting a little bored
not getting stomped out by rioters to be
quite honest with you it's getting a
little boring i want to put myself into
the mix
i don't need all of these ribs you know
i want to get back out there it's
getting spicy in the streets
i want to be on stage at zany's while
everything's burning down
you know uh so we will get out there and
don't worry about that but until then
we're going to be uh how long have we
done by the way uh
40 minutes yeah i mean so don't so if
you if you are
are into seeing us live seeing me live
it's gonna happen
don't worry about it uh it's not going
to be
a situation where uh we never do live
comedy again we're gonna do it again we
just want to find a way to do it
that is fun and safe uh
and uh isn't completely horrible and
doesn't ruin the experience of going out
live
you know we know that money is tight for
a lot of people we don't want to ask you
to buy tickets
uh to a show now i know stand-up new
york has had a lot of uh
success doing comedy shows in pipes
underground new york and i respect that
i resp i mean i haven't been booked but
i respect that
that's very good and you know i
appreciate
listen the mossad needs money they need
money
we're just having fun folks and if you
can't have fun frankly
what can you do well you can grab a
weapon and run into the town square
but i wouldn't recommend it again it's
just not a good idea we all come back to
what is and isn't a good idea it's not a
fun end of summer activity
may i suggest s'mores
and s'mores suck you know what's
interesting about s'mores this is
fascinating
and this is a lot of life this is a lot
of life
the idea of s'mores is good the
the flavor of s'mores is great in other
things
s'mores ice cream s'mores pie
a graham cracker crust with chocolate
pudding
and a marshmallow top i mean nothing
better
but the actual s'more sucks
the actual s'more is not good because
you bite into it
and the marshmallow has only a few
seconds before it becomes too
chewy and the chocolate is either molten
and it's spilling on your hand and
you're getting burned
or it's not melted enough and the graham
crackers are just not good
graham crackers are not good unless
they've been pulverized beyond
recognition
the s'more is a metaphor for a lot of
things in life
where you say to yourself you know this
would probably be good
at its components put another way are
probably really good
but in the way that they're intended
they're not good they don't work in fact
in fact it does not work at all but it's
still a better idea
than shooting people in the street if
we're talking about
just fun end of summer activities even
those s'mores are very hard to get
absolutely i've never had a perfect
s'more have you had a perfect smile
no the process is is the thing that
sucks the most
it's very hard yeah camping is is kind
of a nightmare i mean the one time i
went camping i went with my uncle
and it rained for two days straight and
he spent time uh talking about the
kennedy assassination
and i was eight but i appreciated that i
kind of liked that
uh what terrifies me is if i go camping
again i'll probably go with
people that don't want to talk about the
kennedy assassination and the sun will
come out
that'll be a real hellscape i rode a
bike today for the first time
i i rode a bike on a highway in montauk
like like a monster
you know can you imagine seeing me on a
bike if you see me on a bike
you look at somebody in your car and you
go that guy just killed his wife
if you see me on a bike you go that guy
just strangled his wife in the backyard
and he doesn't want to get in the car
and he doesn't want it but he's on this
bike
for no i mean no there's no good reason
a guy like me is on a bike
i i just did something horrible i'm on
my way to do something horrible
there's just no there's just there's
no way a guy needs anybody it's
undignified
it's it's like a guy like me and a g
like a denim jacket
like a guy like me in a denim jack you
go what the
happened to that person because i know
who i am like
there's people that walk around this
world they have no idea who they are
i have friends that don't know they're
fat they're like women they don't
they don't understand they're fat and i
don't
it's it's fascinating like i had a
friend she called me the other day
i said i said i'm in the hamptons
where's that muffin
the muffin she goes oh round
swamp farms have the best
berry muffin it's got blueberries and
raspberry you know what berries
are
and they're in this muffin and they're
really good and i said where's
muffins because that's a good muffin she
goes let me tell you another muffin
we talked about so then then she tells
me she goes i think she goes i think i'm
fat
because i have uh my body's producing
too much cortisol
which is the stress hormone and she goes
and when you're fat
uh when you have too much cortisol you
don't metabolize fat and you get fat
and you have something called cushing
syndrome or cuffing syndra i don't know
and she goes that syndrome and she goes
i think you have it too
and i said okay and she i said what is
that syndrome because you have skinny
legs and a fat stomach i said but that's
everyone who's fat has that that's
everyone who's fat
and she goes well i think i have it
because i didn't get fat by eating i
said
we just talked about a muffin for seven
minutes
for seven whole minutes we talked about
a muffin she goes i think i have
cushing's
or cooper syndrome i don't know what
syndrome they have but you're gonna know
who you are it doesn't mean i can't lose
weight i'm trying to lose weight i'd
fish today
but the point is i shouldn't really
being on a bike
do you respect anyone on a bike is
anyone on a bike like a person you want
to really spend time with
truly you just don't i forget what
comedian has
a great bit about people on bikes
whatever but i just
don't like the whole thing to me i don't
like i don't like guys on skateboard
scooters
unless they're you know the appropriate
age i don't need we don't need to be
40 on a scooter a segway a skateboard
hoverboard maybe you know but this is
just what it is but i guarantee
somebody saw me on uh somebody on the
bike and just looked
like he's driving his son a little
league and he just goes that man's done
a horrible thing
that sounds like what do you mean daddy
he's on a bike
he just did a horrible thing son he'll
never be he can close his eyes but he'll
never be able to unsee what he did
the kid's like what you got all this
from him being on a bike
guy's like absolutely i did i paid
attention
you know that's where it is that's where
it ends that's where
that's where we find ourselves here it
is 2020 the year of our lord
at the end of august we have found
ourselves in a recession a depression
uh you know we've become uh
a quarantined we've become uh bots
people that exist only online we've
become the bots we're the russian bots
we're the things that everybody warned
you about we've become the you know
shaved head
genderless kind of yeah you know
beady eyes dark blue light
of computer screen in our face all the
time we became those people
run and ruled by fear and anxiety and
depression
we became those people we became that
darkness that darkness online that we
always were scared
was going to infect us we became it for
the last four or five months and now
as we leave our homes we can't shake
that darkness
we can't shake it we just want to watch
burn we want to shoot people we
want to topple
oppressive systems we want to destroy
things we want to burn things because we
can't
figure out how to how to really how to
do anything else
we can't figure out how to make life
better for ourselves
or each other so the only thing that we
can do right now
is to destroy and that's a big problem
and if we don't figure out a way to make
our lives
better we are going to destroy each
other and we're going to destroy this
planet
and that's a big big problem
for me mainly because i just started
selling tickets
so i would like a few years
of entertaining people which i worked
very hard to do
before we start burning this entire
planet down
but that's what you see happening that's
what you see happening with mama bear
rittenhouse
and baby bear kyle when they get in that
car and they get in there with those
guns
they know where they're going they don't
know what's going to happen but they're
going to the end of the world
and they've been training for the end of
the world for a very long time
and you've been training for it too and
it doesn't matter how you want to
experience it you might experience it on
your computer
they might experience it up front they
feel the heat of that
fire and their fingers around
the trigger but we're all
going to the end of the world whether
we're doing it in a van with a gun
or whether we're just logging onto
twitter we're going to the end of the
world and if we keep
traveling in the direction of the end of
the world
the world is going to end so
that's what i'm saying
take your foot off the gas take your
finger off the trigger
walk away go the other way go find a
place that's quiet
think and listen to jerry seinfeld and
james altucher
debate listen to two millionaires debate
the future of new york city a city that
will be fine without either one of them
by the way but we can't keep
our pressure like we cannot keep our
foot on the gas
like this it's going to be very very
very destructive
and the next few months i i fear this
and i don't want to say it
but they're going to be bloody and
they're going gonna be horrible
you know what i mean and and and listen
i don't know i don't know how much
advice you want from me
if you're gonna do it if you're gonna go
if you can't
stop yourself truly if you cannot stop
yourself
from grabbing a weapon and going to
confront
your idea of whatever you think evil is
and you're going to put yourself in hell
don't take a bike goodbye